(bell rings)
(slow music)
(camera clicks)
- I'm just gonna take a nap first.
(dramatic music)
(bell rings)
(dance music)
- Woo hoo. Get a pic.
Uh, you know what, this
really isn't my aesthetic
can I borrow your sunglasses?
Okay, there.
(camera clicks)
Yes, perfect photo.
- I'm done.
(bell rings)
(dramatic vocal music)
(slow music)
(bell rings)
- Okay, okay, move the pillow.
Move the pillow. Good.
Alright, don't smile.
Big eyes. Open your eyes,
but give me the eyes.
Chin up. Okay, not that much up.
Bring it down. Good.
Okay, hair. Need more hair.
Alright, I think we got it.
- Okay.
Oh, you know what, let's
just take like 20 more,
just 20 more.
(bell rings)
- Oh my God, shut up.
Eww, these trash cans stink.
That'll look good on Instagram.
(bell rings)
(breathy music)
- Oh shoot, I forgot to
post something today.
- We're gonna be late for dinner.
- We'll just take a
quick selfie. It's fine.
Actually, you take it.
Okay, look like we're really happy.
(bell rings)
(dance music)
- This looks terrible.
This isn't gonna work.
(silly music)
(horn and bell music)